hey yeah I won't shoot kind of lonesome
back through welfare Oh Oh nope in the
pool
dad why the fancy red suit mr. pool well
that's because it's christmas day
dopinder and i'm after someone on my
naughty list you're probably thinking
this was a superhero movie but that guy
in the suit just turned that other guy
into a [ __ ] kebab surprise this is a
different kind of superhero story to
tell it right we got to take you back
before I squeezed this ass in spandex
mr. Wilson you've recently been
diagnosed with terminal cancer we can
fight this what if I told you we can
cure you and give you abilities most men
only dream of I'd say that you sound
like an infomercial but not a good one
like Slap Chop more shake weighty if I
never see you again know that I love you
when I'm finished it mutates it cells
will heal anything but you still think
we're making you a superior we're making
you receive a slave oh come on you're
gonna leave me all alone here with Jose
Canseco whatever they did to me made me
totally indestructible and completely no
unfuckable you you look like the inside
of other people's [ __ ] I didn't ask
to be super and I'm no hero but when you
find out your worst enemy is after your
best girl
it's
has come to be a [ __ ] superhero right
up Main Street for you to get it on your
own delivered we can't allow this
Deadpool I don't have time for your
x-men [ __ ] Colossus besides nobody's
getting hurt that guy was up there
before we got here
knock-knock when I played a lot of roles
damsel in distress ain't wanna time to
make the chimi [ __ ] chunga's
have you seen this man
I never say this but don't swallow
[ __ ] did I leave the stove on let's go
give it to you yeah you're way too much
dude for me that's why I brought ya
I mean that's why I brought her oh no
finish your tweet it's not it that's
fine just give us a second
go get her tiger oh I so pity the dude
who pressures her into prom sex
hey youtubers it's Charlie Merry
Christmas so they dropped the Deadpool
red band trailer like literally at 12:01
this morning I should have know they
were going to do something crazy so
let's break it down normally I wouldn't
say this but don't swallow coolest new
thing in this trailer is just watching
negasonic teenage warhead get to take
Gina Carano down like a sack of potatoes
now it's just like a small change from
the comics because she's mostly like a
telepath that gets premonitions so I
think what they've done in the movie is
just tune her powers a little bit from
the comics now Gina Carano is playing
angel dust another comic book character
relatively minor comic-book character
that was part of the Morlocks so she's
pretty on point just a little too much
do dinner for Deadpool I do like the
Colossus takedown like the way they play
with your expectations like all Colossus
just gonna like squash her like a grape
open up I guess it's going to be the
really angry teenager mostly other new
scenes are just add some more context
just to give you an idea for the the
tone of the movie you know very funny
but there's that line the Deadpool has
this isn't that kind of superhero movie
he's you know just like letting you know
that this isn't like your typical
superhero story technically he is a hero
but he does very bad things so he's more
of an antihero like the ultimate
antihero for Marvel somewhere in the
background you can hear Rob Liefeld
laughing his ass off oh yeah best Annie
here on the Marvel Universe liberal but
shot in spandex just making fun of the
costume a little bit you really can't do
like a new you know big comic-book
character without having him make fun of
his comic book costume at least a little
bit my favorite one is Wolverine making
fun of the costumes in Bryan Singer's
original x-men film what would you
rather they be yellow spandex somewhere
animated Wolverine is just crying
himself to sleep in his bed a couple
other randos from the Weapon X program
show up and it looks like the way they
explained Deadpool scarred face is that
it happens when he torches the Weapon X
program and they just regenerates like
nothing can kill me so just to explain
why Deadpool's face is so messed up and
it doesn't heal if he has like a healing
factor that's more powerful than
Wolverines you know he has cancer all
over his body like tumors all over his
body so it's the tumors that are causing
the scars on his face he had those
before he got the healing factor and
what the healing factor does is restore
him to that state so even if you were to
cut all the cancerous tumors out of his
body they would instantly grow back
because of the healing factor so it's
kind of a catch-22 like yeah he has this
crazy
in factory you cut his head off he'd
still be alive but he's always gonna
have that messed up face as he says that
makes them undateable now if you read
secret war it's the secret Wars get a
big storyline in that Deadpool's face
does get healed is this really crazy 70s
handlebar mustaches it was like the
freakiest thing the first time I saw it
I was like oh my god that's kind of a
special case normal Deadpool looks just
like this it just completely messed up
face the inside of some nother dudes ass
all new favorite weasel I like the
inside of someone's [ __ ] if you
remember the old trailer there's
actually whenever he's up with Gina
Carano whatever she punches him in the
face when he's in the chair don't leave
me alone with her that line was actually
different in a previous trailer so I
cannot wait to see like the hundreds and
hundreds of takes that they had where
they just try different one-liners maybe
they'll put them on the DVD I think they
just want like different ones for the
green band trailer and different ones
for the red band trailer like just
varying degrees of WTF we get to see a
makers costume start going after the
other Weapon X people don't have time
for your x-men [ __ ]
I wonder if Professor X actually sent
colossus and negasonic teenage warhead
to like make sure Deadpool does it
completely destroy the city somewhere
there's a bollock James McAvoy and
cerebro just shaking his head at Bryan
Reynolds seriously dude's got no chill
they keep including this bridge scene -
this was actually part of the original
test footage they I mean they completely
redid it made it look way better
expanded on it this was what they used
to pitch the Deadpool movie to Fox
executives originally like way way back
in 2011 were they're like here this is
what the movies gonna look like please
greenlight this and it sat on a shelf
forever till it was licked at Comic Con
2014 and then everybody went crazy Fox
was like oh wow we should make this
movie and then you know cut to now where
we actually get the movie especially a
pretty awesome trailer pretty nice thing
for them to drop on Christmas Day
so just given the energy that I'm saying
from this I think the movie is going to
be great I think it will definitely do
good enough to merit a sequel but we
probably won't find out about that till
like after it hits theaters again for a
couple weeks like I think the only
reason that Fox has already greenlit the
next Bryan Singer x-men film is because
they feel like he's so reliable as a
director like even if it doesn't make
five billion dollars it's still going to
be profitable so just like okay even
though your next sequel hasn't come out
even though Paco doesn't come out we're
going to go ahead and get you started
working on the next film after that it
just gives Bryan Singer like their
creative team more time to get ready
because they start to work on scripts to
lock down actors so then when it
actually is time to start rolling
cameras and like you know actually
working they don't have to like scramble
to try and get people it over get hugh
jackman and jennifer lawrence are both
leaving the franchise Michael Fassbender
might stick around and obviously
Apocalypse isn't going to be killed off
like he might not be in every single
movie but he's too powerful for you to
kill off so for the most part the x-men
franchise like the x-men universe that
Fox has will look fairly similar for the
next movie after apocalypse but
hopefully you guys are having an awesome
holiday I have a whole bunch of more
footage to get through so there should
be at least like one more video tonight
and then a couple videos tomorrow and
the day after that I'll be taking a
vacation for like a day or two at the
end of the month but other than that
I've got a bunch of arrow footage I've
got a bunch of legends of tomorrow
footage new flash footage that's
actually cut probably to be later
tonight and then there's new Doctor Who
stuff so if you're wondering when videos
are going to post just follow me on
Facebook and Twitter there are links for
that at the bottom of the description in
case you guys haven't seen I just did a
whole bunch of Star Wars kylo Ren Easter
eggs you can click here for that video
and you can click here for my top ten
Deadpool funny moments thank you so much
for watching everybody
let's have five I'll see you guys
tonight
you